today i was accused of being an internet
sicko a guy that would do anything for
views my accuser lana rhodes she fired
back at me today saying you shouldn't
worry about the nft scam don't you know
there's a war going on saying people who
are concerned about her scamming
investors are being stupid because quote
people are living in fear for their life
in ukraine right now and people are
worried about nfts what does this world
come to and i know what you're thinking
yeah what has this world come to where a
girl can't get a free pass on a scam
dude you hear what putin's doing i mean
look i'm just gonna respond to this real
quick i don't feel like it needs it but
um
we know we know a lot of two bad things
can happen at the same time just just
because we're talking about you doesn't
mean we forgot about the tragedy in
ukraine just because we point out one
bad thing doesn't devalue the other
thing we're all adults here right in
fact i dare i say it we might be able to
hold a third one hold on one second let
me try to create it without losing all
knowledge of ukraine maybe using war as
a cover for your scandals is
bad maybe that i don't know did you guys
all forget about ukraine for a second
honestly i did real quick um but this
rubbed me the wrong way guys in part
because of a situation going on here at
coffeezilla hq many of you guys don't
know about
but those ogs do which is that all of
this all of coffeezilla really is
designed created by a ukrainian even i
am the creation of a ukrainian his name
is ed we've had him on the channel
before aka young pixar as we like to
call him as of yesterday he's stuck in
ukraine he literally can't leave his
country's being invaded but ukraine
won't let young men leave because of
like rules about men under 60 leaving
the country it's very confusing and i've
been calling everyone trying to use
every ounce of influence i have to get
this guy out i barely slept and then
this chick lana rhodes comes and goes
hey stop being mad at me guys you hear
of ukraine
don't you know people are suffering
yeah i think i think we caught that lana
thanks though you know here's a take
that might get me in trouble um just
cause putin exists doesn't mean you're a
good person right just because there's
someone worse than you
and doesn't make you better right maybe
if your argument for why you're a good
person is that you haven't invaded
anyone yet
maybe that's not a good call uh anyway i
got ed's permission to talk about this
um publicly and i just wanted to say
before you you know go to the next part
of this segment if you're in la viv or
have suede to get people out of ukraine
please contact me on twitter or by email
it's all i wanted to say but now with
that out of the way i also want to
address some other stuff that was said
about us me specifically which is that i
was accused of being an effing sicko a
disease of the internet who will do
anything and say anything for views now
i'm going to be honest here i didn't
have it on my bingo card that lana
rhodes would accuse me of being the one
to do anything for reviews but here we
are i guess i'm just wild like that just
just crazy i'll say anything things like
my number one goal for this project is
to increase the value of cryptosys nfts
and make it a lucrative investment for
holders i mean i'll say it oh wait
that wasn't me who said that that that
was lana rhodes she's the one who
abandoned the project and took the money
i mean look honestly guys all i want is
the same thing i've wanted all along
which is for her to return the money to
investors i guess that makes me some
kind of a freak some kind of a disease
of the internet
wanting people's money returned to them
look guys she can't do that right right
how can this millionaire possibly live
on millions of dollars minus like a
million dollars how can she live if her
net worth goes down like a percent i
mean what do you want her to starve what
does this world come to where lana
rhodes is being ridiculed while putin is
invading ukraine
now i will say one positive thing that
has come of my coverage right lana has
once again taken an interest in her nft
out of nowhere posting for the first
time since she disappeared she said it's
on the holders if they're gonna make
their money back quote i'm not saying i
can turn this investment around for
anyone or make anyone profit that is up
to you guys at this point now i do find
this funny that she's basically like
look i'm back but it's all on you
i hold no responsibility here for what
happens to your investment even though
it was all my idea actually look i'm
even saying a partial refund at this
point i'm bargaining dude i'm way past
full refund i'm just saying look she
denies she made 1.5 million dollars
instead lana rhodes says she got a cut
of that but if that's the case fine give
that money back right give that money
back to investors like where's the talk
of that i wonder if they're like in a
room discussing this scandal lana rhodes
has going on and they're talking about
like how to handle it and you know
someone's in the back like hey maybe we
should uh refund them another guy's like
hey maybe we should like deliver on what
we promised everyone and lana rhodes is
like no wait i've got it we'll blame it
on ukraine